she keeps reaching around in the center
console
looks like she's trying to get something
out maybe a handgun
all right gsp has a driver out of the
vehicle
females in custody
that's our girl she just got blonde hair
she does not look happy though
they did just find an old handgun
the gun was right there in the center
was it loaded or no
it was loaded there was a loaded
38 caliber pistol located in the center
console
okay tinny owner just stole us
[Applause]
all right so he's running the dog on him
right now on the van
there it is yeah so the dog alerted on
that back side
door there
oh i see a box on the ground in the back
so it looks like they found it
i mean there's 20 packages so just
depending on
how much they weigh out i think we're
probably going to be close to 25 kilos
so we're taking the female passenger and
the driver to jail
you want him on this side they'll be
charged with trafficking
and then the male will have some
firearms charges as well
everybody did what they were supposed to
do you know it went as
fluid as it could have and uh you know
we took a large
quantity of methamphetamine off the
street right now we're just going down
to the precinct
i'll see if about getting a test kit
we'll test the drug see if it's
methamphetamine
very good for law enforcement today and
not so good for the bad guys
[Music]
you